famous celebrity photographer to do
photographs of us what's the big deals
we have perfectly nice cameras right
here it's pretty easy to tell why I am
excited because top 10 games you can
play in your head by yourself is finally
live on amazon.com and ready for
purchase it is $19.99 and I can I can
attest that it is one heck of a deal for
a third of the price of an average video
game you get hours if not months if not
years of gameplay in your own mind the
back of the book says it all your minds
the ultimate gaming engine amazing one
of the deciding factors in us bringing
this book to life was hearing all the
stories of players who had played these
games before us everyone has a different
experience when going again into one I
haven't heard the same story about space
twice this leads me to one thing one
small small request if you buy this book
and if you enjoy when you leave your
review on Amazon don't just leave a
review of the book share a story that
you experienced sharing your story is
the best way to get people excited about
what's inside this book we got a problem
we got invited to take part in the
professional photography shoot with
Andrew Echols who is one of the guys
when it comes to photography for
everything from artists to politicians
to people of fame and YouTube they want
to basically take better photos for
corridor so it's a good thing but the
problem is I don't know if you've looked
around but in a studio with 9 dudes
things can get a little I guess hygiene
isn't exactly the highest priority
recently I did get a haircut recently
and that made me think something with
Christian about this and our friend
George it was one of the best haircuts
in all of LA he owns two barbershops bar
code barbers so we're gonna have them
come down today what is it why why are
we doing a photo shoot YouTube invited
us to get photographed by some like
famous photographer this is super high
profile what's the big deal we have
perfectly nice cameras right here
I think you just salty because you to be
the last banana photos oh nice try nice
try
he almost got me there in like to make
matters worse Clinton never had a beer
to his whole life till he started
working here and then he grew a beard to
emergency is being handled our friends
at bars or a barbershop are here to give
all the dudes a nice fresh cut now you
can take people with you in this quest
all right this Saturday we're
self-publishing a town wait you mean
today me and a friend basically just
updated and we edited lots of the stuff
and basically good they're like it's
like super old trying to figure out mo
guys can't figure out what kind of
haircut they want or if it's just me
so usually I just do like shave the
sides kind of fade up right and then I
like to keep some of the curls like
whatever you think
it's like such a surreal experience at
work so this is our good friend George
Laura the founder and owner of bark oh
yes he actually used to live with me and
Jake he and Jake were looking for a
roommate he's still lived in Temecula
back where my hometown is he cut my hair
like on my 21st birthday 27 now but he
cut my hair my 21st birthday a couple
months later I called him I was like yo
there's a room available in the house
once you moved to LA and give it a shot
and he came out glad to be where I'm at
now you know got to get support from my
close friends right he'll be here so
[Music]
tell me about the first remember
cheering oh my my first haircut was on
Columbus Avenue in North Beach in San
Francisco I think it's still there told
Kim's same lady still runs the place
that's my first haircut it's great but
yeah I grew up in San Francisco so the
first six six seven years my life let's
forgot my haircut I think I went back I
said hi once like seven years ago but
that surprised her that surprised my own
barber I left when I was seven and I
came back when I was like 22 I was like
hey you don't never range
your big run yeah brah nice man
[Music]
playing chess right
well the book is great I'm gonna round
you so I get a chance to read the book
that Sam and his buddy David edited I
also get to sit next to the two guys who
I stood next to every day never getting
haircuts now I was leaving I love Harry
joonyoung's
come back well crisis averted all the
dudes are freshly cut and ready for a
photo shoot tomorrow thanks to our
friends at bar code barbershop so they
actually have two locations in West
Hollywood for special corridor fans if
you book online and use corridor 15 code
you get 15% off your first cut thanks
for coming out again yes thanks for
having me appreciate it for having the
team we're gonna send everybody a
haircuts to you yep that's pretty good
man
the first time I was like pressing in my
head
[Music]
which indeed should I be nervous
Ram yes Andrew thank you your neck neck
Andrew which means Christian hey
Christian I'm Andrew let's try to
cluster you together and something right
right yeah all right you know let's have
a look here we're definitely gonna need
to go up on this in height and power
yeah so you know it's a little it's a
little staircase this is one way yeah
everyone has one hand on someone's
shoulder that's funny relax you know
normal photo but who wants that let me
try let me try this it may or may not
work but it's gonna be pretty
uncomfortably close Sam do your best to
do best to slide through just when you
think that you're way too close in
general yeah it's definitely serious
really yeah
Sam serious good a couple more serious
cuz Nico can't find it find it yeah
maybe might yeah mildly horrified good
nice very casual releasing it very very
gradually rights transfer just got right
release rush so all you guys can see it
pro it's worth we also very like we have
formal outfits like suits you're gonna
have us three like in suits and every
else casual as well if you want
it's funny that's fun we got a minute do
you ever change yeah our stuffs like
right outside let's do it real quick
[Music]
[Applause]
forget the most important thing in the
world Wow crazy that was a lot of fun
yeah
andrew is super cool just like I've
never like looked at a photo on a screen
be like that is the most Pro film I've
ever seen I saw some of the best photos
from any of you guys today
like I was just really cool and as we
did for you as well I mean you're
looking great he you walk in there you
get a feel for how he's doing it and you
realize this guy's seen more photographs
taking more photographs and studied it
more than probably it there's probably
only a handful of people on earth who
have that sort of knowledge in the old
the old brain it's very specialized you
know you just you just let them take the
reins and used to go with it super cool
yeah I was really man I walked in there
I was like man we got nice cameras in
this video what's the big deal who for
dreamers cameras were here and I walk in
and dude took my breath away
the guy's got such a cool camera oh my
god so much better flashing lights to
save on battery power so I can take
pictures all day when you set in there
you're under the aura of somebody who
seem to be doing a simple task but
underneath that simplicity was years and
years of wisdom and confidence and a
deft touch of an experienced artist oh
well he's also a man who's looked at
many beautiful men and women famous ones
and when you standing underneath his
lights and in front of his camera and he
tells you that you're looking good man
what a warm fuzzy feeling that is this
book is so real that you can go on
Amazon right now and by it from 1999
it's an incredible book i co edited it
with my friend David and boy we had a
great time it's originally based on the
works of JC a'practice Bartholomew's
groundbreaking series games you can play
in your head by yourself we
the 10 best of them put them right here
for you and one easy to read paper man
go by now